[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un soleil sur lequel on n'osait pas
compter amené à Longchamp la foule des
grands jours pour l'événement de la
saison hippique le Grand Prix de Paris
[Musique]
dès le départ après l'arrêt m'a pris la
tête de ses 18 concurrents mais avec ces
3000 mètres le parcours laisse toute
latitude aux émotions
après le moulin l'oracle mène devant
château d'Espagne et Prince courageux
[Musique]
à l'entrée de la ligne droite Prince
courageux est apparu en tête du peloton
mais s'ignore comme et la faute d'ouvrir
la corde et le jockey point Slee yanguf
au Sanctus et ses Sanctus déjà
vainqueurs du prix du Jockey Club qui
termine avec une longueur
sa victoire fait tomber une pluie de
millions sur les œufs gagnants bien sûr
il n'y en a pas pour tout le monde
[Musique]
mais on peut toujours se consoler car la
tranche spéciale du 14 juillet annonce
une nouvelle averse de 66000 lots
représentant un milliard 400 millions
d'anciens francs bien entendu
24 comme 24 Heures du Mans sous ce
chiffre Panhard vient de dévoiler à la
presse ces nouveaux modèles 24 C coachs
et 24 CT coupés qui continuent la série
des 17
un système de réglage du volant et des
sièges avant qui permet de réaliser un
poste de pilotage sur mesure et s'ajoute
aux qualités traditionnelles de lapin
art confort freinage économie et très
grande visibilité la route secours
trouve place sous le coffre arrière dans
un logement spécial rendez-vous au
prochain salon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sous le signe d'une amitié
franco-marocaine demeurer vivante depuis
l'indépendance que s'est déroulée la
visite du roi du Maroc Hassan II à Paris
est l'un de ses premiers gestes a été de
se recueillir sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu le général de Gaulle fait
exceptionnel avait tenu à être à ses
côtés
[Musique]
c'est cette amitié qui compte évoqué
dans leurs entretiens avec l'avenir de
la coopération entre leur pays les deux
chefs d'État
[Applaudissements]
c'est cette amitié enfin compte exalter
les plus hautes personnalités des deux
pays au cours de la réception donnée au
Palais de l'Élysée en l'honneur du roi
rassan II nos deux pays a dit le
souverain marocain marcheront côte à
côte dans un avenir de coopération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la porte de Brandebourg masquée du
côté soviétique par des minces panneaux
monsieur Kennedy a jeté un coup d’œil
sur le secteur oriental qui a tout
récemment accentué sa séparation par la
création le long du fameux mur d'une
zone interdite de 100 mètres de largeur
[Musique]
et c'est à une foule immense que
Monsieur Kennedy a adressé ses paroles
qui ont produit une grosse sensation
tous les âmes libres d'où qu'il soit son
citoyen de Berlin et moi-même en tant
qu'homme libre je suis fier de dire je
suis berline
ces paroles n'ont pas manqué d'avoir un
écho de l'autre côté de cette barrière
inhumaine où s'est enfermé depuis deux
ans Berlin est dans le but d'arrêter la
fuite vers l'ouest des populations
de l'autre côté de cette barrière dans
l'autre Berlin monsieur Nikita cochov
est arrivé deux jours après le départ du
président américain voyage réponse
peut-être mais que l'on explique par
l'anniversaire du président de
l'Allemagne de l'Est monsieur oubridge
monsieur kruchev a rencontré à Berlin
Est les dirigeants des états communistes
et en dehors des discussions de doctrine
nul doute qu'il est abordé avec eux le
problème des relations Est-Ouest et
celui de l'Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
dans ce coin des Hautes-Alpes ils ne
sont sans doute pas rares ces chemins ou
rien ne passe sinon parfois un troupeau
mais ce chemin ne mène pas seulement à
la montagne il a pour aboutissement un
village saint-ciris et quel village
voici bientôt 20 ans le dernier habitant
a quitté sa maison pour l'hospice depuis
rien n'a changé les portes bat Thauvin
les murs se désagrègent saint-ciris est
devenu un spectre seul encore presque
intact la mairie qui est à la fois
église et école demeure debout au milieu
de son cimetière envahi par l'herbe
[Musique]
personne ne vient plus prier ici
personne ne vient plus s'asseoir sur ses
bancs pourtant cette commune qui compte
à 80 électeurs a toujours une existence
légale étrange commune sans le moindre
habitant mais dont la mairie continue à
fonctionner étrange conseil dont cinq
membres sur 9 appartiennent à la même
famille et qui administre un village
mort madame je m'excuse assistant nous a
une séance du conseil municipal de
saint-ciris ou à une réunion de famille
c'est une réunion du conseil municipal
monsieur mais également à une réunion de
famille parce que nous sommes ici c'est
un arbre de la même famille et puis la
minorité de l'autre côté du conseil
municipal nous nous sommes toujours
d'accord quand il s'agit du bien de la
commune
devant cette réunion on peut s'étonner
comment un village abandonné peut-il
encore avoir un conseil municipal
effectivement c'est un village abandonné
seul voisin qui possède des terres sur
la commune de saint-cyris sur
saint-cyris et de ce fait qui ont le
droit de d'être conseiller municipaux
dans cette commune saint-cyrise a été
abandonné Monsieur Pascal 1910 plusieurs
propriétaires ont vendu à l'état c'est à
dire aux Eaux et Forêts et du fait du
reboisement et bien plusieurs propriétés
ont dû quitter encore le pays parce
qu'il n'avait plus assez de surface de
pour vivre
voilà saint Cyris la commune la plus
insolite de France une mairie n'est plus
de village un maire mais pas de
population
saint-ciris qui totalement abandonné
figure toujours sur la liste des
communes de France se survit hors de
toute réalité saint-cyris ou la commune
fantôme
[Musique]
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
les cérémonies du couronnement du pape
se seront déroulés d'un bout à l'autre
sur le parvis de Saint-Pierre face au
ciel devant la foule des chrétiens
[Applaudissements]
dans la parade traditionnelle qui
rappelle les fastes de la Renaissance Sa
Sainteté Paul 6 a gagné l'hôtel dressé
devant la basilique
là le 262E successeur de Saint-Pierre
l'évêque de Rome a célébré la messe du
couronnement en présence des
représentants de 80 nations parmi
lesquelles on reconnaissait Monsieur
Georges Pompidou qui représentait la
France le prince Constantin de Grèce
le roi des Belges et la reine Fabiola
et voici l'instinct solennelle le
Souverain Pontife reçoit des mains du
cardinal octaviani la tiare aux Trois
Couronnes
[Musique]
et au son de toutes les cloches de RAM
aux acclamations de 250 000 personnes le
pape regagne le Vatican un nouveau règne
commence
[Musique]